Bruce Willis all smiles posing with his
family for Holiday photos months after
revealing he's stepping away from acting
amid his health issues there are a lot
of of you know of rewards to being in
successful films and you know being a
successful actor but I'm doing this
because I really enjoy doing it Bruce's
ex Demi Moore shared a few snaps of
their festive get-together that's to me
locked in Bruce's arms as his wife Emma
hemming grins next to the actress Emma
and Bruce's daughters Mabel and Evelyn
were also part of the adorable photo as
were to me and Bruce's daughters rumor
Scout and Tallulah Demi also shared this
sweet moment of Emma and Bruce holding
hands and this photo cuddled up with the
GI Jane Stars dog pilaf Demi captions
the pics We Are Family getting into the
holiday spirit with Emma commenting what
a fun evening I think you just separate
the part that says Hollywood and you you
know remember what it really is just to
be a family and and you know families
are there for each other in the UPS
downs and The Good The Bad and um really
just making sure you make time for each
other back in March the ladies and
Bruce's life all shared a joint
statement on Instagram revealing he was
diagnosed with Aphasia a disorder
impacting his cognitive abilities and as
a result Bruce is stepping away from the
career that has meant so much to him
athenia is a condition that results from
damage to the speech areas of the brain
it's actually quite common in certain
neurological conditions that we treat
within Hospital Systems the disease
causes a gradual loss speech and the
ability to understand language it's
usually a result of a stroke head injury
or brain tumor for Bruce the cause is
unclear
though so it will be very important
important to get a hold of a speech and
language pathologist I say that your
quality of life is greatly affected by
Aphasia it is something that's brand new
that is not familiar to you however with
good adaptive methods and ways to
compensate for the Aphasia you can still
have a good quality of life when you
have this condition
the family added that though this is a
really challenging time they appreciate
all the love and support from fans quote
we are moving through this as a strong
family unit and wanted to bring his fans
in because we know how much he means to
you as you do to him they concluded
their post writing as Bruce always says
live it up and together we plan to do
just that
the house don't fall when my bones are
good
[Music]
today